devant les caméras des agences russes
cet homme annonce son vote je choisis
oui sans hésitation et je le dis au
monde entier
son choix est de toute façon visible le
vote ne se déroule pas à bulletin secret
nous mettons nos espoirs on la Russie
avec toute notre force tout notre cœur
et tout notre esprit nous voulons
rentrer à la maison le plus vite
possible nous voulons que la Russie nous
prenne sous son aile dans la région
voisine à luansk les militaires
séparatistes votent et là aussi le
bulletin n'est pas secret
aujourd'hui quelque chose qu'on
attendait après 8 ans de souffrance
arrivant enfin aujourd'hui nous avons
notre référendum les Ferrières quatre
zones géographiques soit 15% du
territoire ukrainien vote pour être
rattaché à la Russie les deux
républiques séparatistes de louantes ce
qui est denietzk et les régions occupées
de zaporigia et Carson dans la ville de
zapporija ceux qui ont fui la partie de
la région sous occupation russe sont
furieux
je ne soutiens pas ce référendum quelle
loi vous donne le droit de démanteler
l'Ukraine les réfugiés de Carson
partagent le même avis
je suis contre ce référendum personne
n'appartient à l'Ukraine
ces référendum se tiendront jusqu'à
mardi